QINGYANG CHEN:
Welcome to our talk.
We're going to be talking
about building containers
faster with Jib, which is a
container image builder we
built for Java applications.
APPU GOUNDAN: So who are we?
We're a team based
out of New York.
We build tools for Java
developers targeting the cloud.
I'm Appu.
QINGYANG CHEN: And I'm Q. So
cloud deployments nowadays are
moving from VMs to containers.
Many of you are probably already
familiar with containers,
which allow you
to, say, split up
your application
into micro-services
and orchestrate these with
tools such as Kubernetes.
And Java developers are already
familiar with building jars.
Containers are sort
of the same concept.
The idea behind Java is
very similar to the idea
behind containers, which is
this idea of write once, run
anywhere.
However, building containers
for Java applications
can be quite a confusing
and tricky process.
APPU GOUNDAN: So let's go
through an example of a Java
developer who is
new to containers
and trying to figure out
how to write a docker file
to build a container.
QINGYANG CHEN: All right.
So let's say I'm
a Java developer
and I'm building a
website for a pet clinic.
I want to containerize my
back end-- my Java back end.
And I want my container
image to be on my registry
at ilovejava.io/petclinic-app.
So what do I do first?
I go and I search build
Java docker image.
And I read the top
few tutorials and I'm
able to write this docker file.
So I run Docker Build, but
it takes a very long time
to actually do the build.
APPU GOUNDAN: So some of you may
have already written a docker
file like this, but to
see what's going on here,
you're choosing a
base image, you're
installing a bunch of things--
Python software properties,
some other stuff
I don't really understand.
You have to install Java 8.
You have to accept
the Oracle license.
Then you run Install Maven.
You put your application
on your container
and then you do your
build on your container.
It's a lot going on.
There might be a way to
simplify this and remove
all the unnecessary runs.
QINGYANG CHEN: OK.
So I read some more
tutorials and I'm
able to write this much
better docker file.
I'm using a well-maintained
base image-- the openjdk base
image off of Docker Hub.
And all I'm doing is I'm copying
my fat jar into my container
image and setting my entry
point to run that fat jar.
It's a lot simpler--
a lot fewer layers.
APPU GOUNDAN: So this is nice.
It's very obvious
what's going on here.
I understand all the lines.
However, when I
ran this build, I
saw that my image was
over 300 megabytes.
And I know some people are
concerned about disk space.
So maybe there's a way
to make this smaller.
QINGYANG CHEN: So OK.
So I do some research and I
find that the openjdk base
image is 284 megabytes by
itself, and that's huge,
making my entire application
over 300 megabytes.
So I do some more
searching and I
find that I can actually use
the Alpine version of openjdk.
Alpine is a tiny
Linux distribution,
which, by itself, is
only about 4 megabytes,
and most only just
using a JRE version.
So this base image
is only 82 megabytes,
making my entire
image a lot smaller
than what I started with.
However, it seems that
when I run the build,
it still takes a
while to do the build.
APPU GOUNDAN: So it's
not obvious from here,
but when you do a docker
build, the first step
is sending the context
over to the docker daemon.
And the context
is everything you
need to build your container.
By default, the context is
everything in the directory
with your docker file.
But in here, you see we only
need our pet clinic fat jar.
So maybe there is a way
we can limit what we send.
QINGYANG CHEN: OK.
So I do some more searching.
I find that there is a
docker file best practices,
and that's a lot
of best practices.
I see in there there's something
about a docker ignore file.
So I do some research
on docker ignore files
and I'm able to write
this docker ignore file.
It ignores everything
in my project directory
except for the fat jar that I
want to copy into my container
image.
So now, my build
runs a lot faster,
so I can now do docker push and
how my image be on registry.
But it seems that even if I just
change a single line of code,
my push still takes a while.
Why is that?
APPU GOUNDAN: So usually,
every line in your docker file
creates a new layer and
your image is made up
of a bunch of layers.
In our example,
one of our layers
is our whole application.
So if you change a tiny part
of your application, when
you build, you have to
create that layer again.
You have to send it over.
If your application
is pretty large,
then that might take a while.
Perhaps there is a way we
can split our application
into smaller layers.
QINGYANG CHEN: OK.
So I do some more
tutorials and I'm
able to write this
better docker file.
I split up my application
to two layers--
one for my dependency jars
and one for my classes files.
This way, when I only
change my classes files,
the only layer that I need to
resend when I do a docker push
is my classes layer, and not
my usually much larger layer
with my dependency jars.
So I think I'm
good to go, right?
APPU GOUNDAN: Yeah,
except it looks
like we still need
to run some Maven
goals to prepare for our build.
That's the problem
with having two
build files is you have to
maintain two build files.
Maybe there's a way we
can do this in Maven.
QINGYANG CHEN: OK.
So I do some more
searching and I
find that there are
actually Maven plug plugins
that I can use to define my
docker build within my Maven
Palm XML.
So I delete my four
lines of docker file,
add just 20 lines of
Maven configuration.
I'll do my entire
build from Maven.
Great.
I think I'm good to go.
APPU GOUNDAN: So there
was a lot going on here.
We wrote a docker file that
we found on the internet,
we tried to reduce
the image size,
we tried to reduce how much
happened in the docker file,
we added a docker
ignore, we tried
splitting our application up.
We even tried this Spotify
Maven plugin, which we're aware
is deprecated, but it's
great for this example.
There's other things
we didn't cover.
You have to download
and install docker.
The order of layers
in your docker file
kind of determines
your cache hits.
You can use multistage builds.
There's more docker cache
things to be aware of,
and finally, you have
to have your docker
daemon running as root.
Our colleague, Ray, has some
more docker tips and tricks.
If you're interested, that's
not the point of our talk,
but if you want to take a
look, it's at this link here.
We're going to show this
link again at the end.
QINGYANG CHEN: So when
containerized with docker,
there's many steps that
exist between your project
and your container
image actually
being on your registry.
You have to build your jar, you
have to write your docker file,
you have to send that along with
your jar via that docker client
to the docker daemon.
And then the docker daemon
has to run a container
or to build your
container image,
and then pushes that contain
image to the registry.
But we're all Java developers.
We don't want to have to
care about docker files.
The containerization
process should
be as simple as having your
project running some build
and having your container
image just be on your registry.
So in our example, we have
our pet clinic project,
we run some build, and we should
just have our container image
just exist on our registry.
So that's why we built Jib.
We built Jib as plugins
for Maven or Gradle
so that you can containerize
your existing Maven or Gradle
projects in two easy steps.
Just apply the plugin
and run the build.
So, now we'll give you guys
a demo of how Jib works.
So we're using the
spring pet clinic
project, which is a sample
project from the spring
frameworks projects.
And I'm going to go--
so right now, I
have it opened up,
and I'm going to go
into presentation mode
so you guys can actually see.
So this is the Palm XML for
the sample spring pet clinic
project.
Go into the plugins, and I'm
going to apply the Jib plugin.
I just set as a live
template, so that's just
going to apply the Jib plugin.
Scroll that up a little bit.
So this is just
apply and plug in.
I'm setting where I
want my image to be at
once it's containerized.
This is just a demo project
I've set up on Google Cloud,
and I'm using Google Container
Registry as my registry.
So now I can go
into my terminal.
This directory was the project.
I just do a Maven
compile Jib build.
What this is going
to do-- it's going
to run through the normal
compilation for that spring
framework project.
And after that
compilation finishes,
it's going to run
the containerization
with Jib Build.
So now it's running
Jib Build and it's
building a container image.
And once that's done, we'll
be able to grab the image
reference, which is right here.
This is the image reference that
we set in our configuration,
and we're just going to
use docker to show you guys
that we can run this container.
So right now, I just cleared
everything in my docker images
already, and I'm going to do
docker-- run with that image
reference.
And I'm going to just
expose the port 8080 so
that we can hit it from a web
browser and see it in action.
So this is going to pull that
image and run that image.
And once this
starts, you can see
our application is starting up
from within the container we
just containerized with
strip, colon, build.
Once that starts up, we'll be
able to go to the web browser
and just hit the logo host 8080.
And we see our demo pet
clinic application start up
from within the container.
All right, great.
Let's get back to
the presentation.
APPU GOUNDAN: So
in this demo, you
saw we did a Jib build, which
takes your Java application
and puts it in a
container on a registry.
But some of you still have
docker infrastructure,
and maybe you still want to
try this with your existing--
is it down?
QINGYANG CHEN: Yeah.
APPU GOUNDAN: So
we have one option
to build to a docker
daemon you might
have running locally, using
for tests or whatever.
And then we can even
generate a docker context
with a docker file that does the
same build that we do in Jib.
And you can use your docker
build to create an image.
In the example, it was
all default config,
but you can set JVM flags, you
can choose your output image
format, you can use OCI.
We have multiple ways to set
your credentials you need
for pulling and pushing
to private registries,
and there's an option to set
the program arguments that you
pass to your main method.
So we want Jib to feel more
like a compiler for containers.
If you look at a docker file,
it kind of feels like a script.
You choose a base image, you run
a bunch of arbitrary commands.
You can even run your
build inside your container
for your application, and then
you configure the endpoint.
But a containerizer that's
integrated into your
build tool should have
enough information
to do all of that for
you without having
to go to a second build.
So historically, code has been
compiled into an executable,
and a containerizer should
take your Java application
and just build it
into a container.
And Java-- we've been
doing this for a while.
You take your application and
your jar it up into a jar.
And with Jib, you
take your application
and you Jib it up
into a container.
So let's go into a little
bit of how Jib works.
QINGYANG CHEN: So we
kept a few goals in mind
when we were developing Jib.
First, we wanted to have
Jib be purely in Java,
so that you can containerize
your Java project with nothing
but just your Maven or
Gradle build systems.
We wanted Jib to be
optimized for Java occasions
so that you can deploy your
changes fast and incrementally.
And we wanted Jib to be able
to build images reproducibly.
So we implemented Jib
completely in Java
so that you can build
with just your Maven
or Gradle build systems,
and the benefits of these
are that you don't need to
install docker or have docker
CLI.
You don't need to run
the docker daemon.
You don't need to have root
in order to run that daemon,
and you're not actually
running a container
in order to build a container.
So how do we achieve this?
Well, first, it
helps to understand
what a container image is.
A container image is just
a directory of files,
and in the docker image
format, this directory of files
is split up into layers,
each represented as tarballs,
and these tarballs composed
into the actual file
system for the container.
And in this format,
there is also
a container
configuration, including
things such as
environment variables,
entry points, volume
amounts, exposed ports--
things for when you're
actually running a container.
So this an example of a
container configuration.
You add the checksums for
layers, and an example--
there's also an entry
point set, which
is a command that's run when
the container image is run.
And then in this
format, there's also
a manifest that just wraps
up all the components
of the container image--
your layers and your
container configuration.
This is an example of manifests.
You have just IDs of the layers
and the configuration, as well.
These are also checksums.
So in the Jib image, we
build our application layers
on top of the
distroless/Java base image.
Distroless is a set of
language focused base images
for languages such
as Java, Python, Go--
and these images
don't include anything
but just what is necessary
to run your application
in that language.
So compare this to
Alpine, for example,
which is a popular base
image recommended by docker.
Alpine's still a
Linux distribution.
It's just a tiny
Distroless, on the
other hand, doesn't
include package
managers, shells,
or any other
unnecessary programs,
but just what is necessary.
So this helps to
improve security
by reducing possible
attack surfaces.
It helps to keep
your containment
image as minimal as possible.
This is essentially what
a container should be.
It should be just
your application
and its runtime dependencies.
So if you guys want to
learn more about distroless,
our colleague, Matt,
has a great talk
that's linked to in the
distroless repository.
APPU GOUNDAN: So speed.
If we're trying to
replace your docker build,
we want to be as fast or faster
than what you were previously
getting.
So the way builds
work in docker is
you create a bunch of images.
See, in this example, you have
a 100 megabyte, say, base layer
and a 50 megabyte application.
When you push it to a registry,
it sends both layers over.
However, when you
make a change, it only
sends the layer that's changed.
So let's say we change
something in our application
and we do a docker
build and push.
This layer is rebuilt
and pushes the registry.
And even a possibly
better way to do it
is to split your
application even more.
Let's say here, 49 and 1, and
if we'd done it correctly,
we're making all our
changes during development
in this 1 megabyte layer.
So our sends are quick and they
send very little over the wire.
In Jib, we don't
use a docker file,
but this is what we
think an optimized docker
file might look like
for a Java application.
You see it's split into
dependencies, resources,
and classes, and then
we have an endpoint
that ties it all together.
But Jib doesn't
use a docker file.
It still builds like this.
So here's a small
example of showing you
how you get speed improvements.
Your first build
using Jib or docker--
this docker is a docker
file example that we
found on a spring tutorial.
It uses a single layer
for your application,
as opposed to three
layers, like we do in Jib.
And your first
build is the same.
You have to send everything
over to the registry.
If you rebuild without changes,
they're both pretty fast
because they just have to go
through the motions of deciding
nothing's changed.
However, when you
rebuild with changes to,
let's say, just
your class files,
Jib is only going to
resend your classes layer,
whereas a traditional
docker build
will send your whole
application over because that's
what you told it to do.
And here, it's the difference
between 5 and, say, 15 seconds.
But if you look at a much larger
application down at the bottom,
when you change, this one
might be heavy on dependencies
and resources.
So when you change
classes, again, Jib
is only sending a
small layer over,
while your traditional
docker build
is going to send the
whole thing over.
And that, in this
case, takes 35 seconds,
which is a lot of time to
be waiting for your build.
QINGYANG CHEN: So
another benefit
we get out of a
custom image builder
like Jib is the ability to
build images reproducibly.
So what does
reproducibility mean?
Reproducibility means
that the same code always
produces the same image.
So for example, if you
were to make a change
and commit that to, say,
your version control,
that commit should produce
the same image on your machine
as your teammate's machine, your
production machine, or your CIC
system.
And what this helps
you do is produce
possible variations that could
occur in a production container
build that you can't reproduce
in a local development build.
So how do we achieve
reproducibility?
Well, we just wipe
all the metadata
that could vary between builds,
such as time stamps, user
IDs, and groups.
So now that we've talked a
little bit about how Jib works,
there's still much
more that we can
do to improve the
containerization experience.
APPU GOUNDAN: So
this is kind of what
we're hoping to cover in
our next versions of Jib.
We can have smarter
inferences, we
can try and figure out what
port you need to expose and do
that for you with these
other container optimizations
based on your Java application,
like how much memory you need
or how much CPU you might need.
We can try to organize
your layers logically,
based on what code we think
is going to change together.
So we can hopefully have
faster builds there.
And then Java modules--
they let you reduce
the size of your JRE,
and we could possibly reduce
the size of your container
completely.
So we've covered the build
part, but we're still
trying to make it easier
for Java developers
to get their code
running on a container.
And our next demo is
an experimental plugin
we're working on to help
during development that'll
get your Jib built image
running and available
for debugging on Kubernetes.
QINGYANG CHEN: So
now, we'll give
a demo of the experimental
plugin we've been developing
for being able to run
and debug your Jib
build container on Kubernetes.
So just a little bit of context.
Kubernetes is a tool for
being able to orchestrate
your containers across
a cluster of machines.
And here, before
a demo, we already
set up a Kubernetes cluster
on Google Kubernetes engine.
It's very easy to do.
All you need to do is
run that one command.
So we already had that set up.
We're going to go
into our terminal
and we're going to stop this
container from last demo.
And so kubecontrol is the
command line interface
for interacting with
your Kubernetes cluster.
Can everyone see
this in the back?
Is it good?
All right.
So I'm just going to show that
we have an empty Kubernetes
cluster setup.
This might take a little while.
Every time, first
time you run it,
it might be fishing
credentials-- something.
In the meantime-- so we're
going to go and apply
the experimental plugin
we've been developing.
So I have this as a
live template, as well.
So what I'm doing is
I'm applying this plugin
without any configuration.
It'll be able to just
use the Jib's image.
So this is called the Kubernetes
dev Maven plugin for now.
Let's go back to terminal.
So you can see the
cluster is set up
with just Kubernetes running.
So now, what we can do is
we can take a project--
or Maven project-- and
do Maven Kubernetes dev,
and we'll do the
debug goal for being
able to debug our application.
I'm going to expose
the Port 8080 again,
and what this is
going to do is it's
going to generate the
Kubernetes manifests.
It's going to deploy those
manifests to the Kubernetes
cluster, and it's running the
application-- the container
and the application with
the debugger agent library
and exposing that port and
actually forwarding that port
to our computer, so that
we can debug it in our IDE.
So what we can do now is
we can go back to our IDE
and go into--
it might be a little
harder to see,
but Run, Edit Configurations,
and all we're going to do
is we're going to add a default
remote bugging configuration.
So add a default remote, and
we're just going to press OK.
And now what we can
do is we can go to Run
and just debug that
configuration we just made.
And now our IDE's
debugger is connected
to our application that's
running in our Kubernetes
cluster.
So as you can see, the
application is starting up,
and once this starts
up, we can actually
hit it from our web browser.
But first, let's see
what is in the cluster.
So as you can see, the
pet clinic application
has started up as a
service in the cluster,
and it's generated
an external IP
that we can actually hit live.
Anyone can actually
hit it in this room.
So we can go there.
Let's first see if
it's started up.
It is started up.
OK.
So let me make this bigger.
So as you can see, it's running
on our Kubernetes cluster,
just like it was running
locally in our container.
So this is in a
container on Kubernetes.
So let's say we want
to do some debugging.
We want to, let's say, just
don't show any veterinarians.
So what we can do is we
can perform a hot swap.
So we can go back
to IDE, and let's
go to the controller
for that page--
the /vets.html.
And let's just
comment out the line
that just adds all the
veterinarians to the page.
You can save that, go
to build, recompile.
So this will recompile
the class and it'll
ask us to do the hot spot.
So asks if it's a real class.
Yes.
We'll reload it, and this
will swap out the class
that's running on Kubernetes.
So now, if you go back
to our page and refresh,
we'll see that there's
no veterinarians left.
Cool.
Let's go back to
the presentation.
All right.
So that was a lot of
stuff we just did,
but what did we just do?
We took our project, we
ran some Maven plugin.
A goal was a Maven plugin.
And it put our application
in containerized form
on Kubernetes for us
to be able to bug.
And we were able to
use our IDE to attach
to our running application and
debug our application that's
running in remote
cluster as if it was
a locally running application.
APPU GOUNDAN: So
you saw the tools
we built for helping you build--
stuff we're working on to
help your run and deploy.
The future now is
we're trying to make
Jib available as a library
instead of just plugins.
So if you're building your
own container builder tools,
you can use the
library underneath
and have a lot of it
taken care of for you.
We want to release the debug
and run plugin, possibly
using Scaffold underneath.
If any of you are
familiar with that,
that's another team at
Google that we work with.
And finally-- we
know this is hard,
but we want Java
developers to be
able to run their Java
applications on a container
cluster without having to know
anything about containers.
QINGYANG CHEN: So Jib
is now available in beta
and you can find it at
our GitHub repository.
And we welcome you to check
it out, tweet about us,
blog about us, and
leave us feedback.
And we have quite a few
minutes for questions.
So let us know if you
have any questions.
We'll also probably be at
the Google booth afterwards.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]
APPU GOUNDAN: No questions.
QINGYANG CHEN: Yes.
APPU GOUNDAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you integrate
it to the Maven release cycle?
QINGYANG CHEN: So the
question is, how do you
integrate it to the Maven--
the Raven cycle of
the life cycle, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
QINGYANG CHEN: Yeah.
So you can actually add it
to a phase-- lifecycle phase
and just have it execute.
So the plugin-- you can define
executions for the build goal
and have it execute on the phase
that you want it to execute on.
APPU GOUNDAN: As long as
it happens after compile.
Presumably, you would
put it in package,
which is where most
builders or packagers go,
and we're kind of
a packaging tool.
QINGYANG CHEN: Yeah,
and this is also
available as a Gradle
plugin, so in Gradle, it
would be you can set a
dependency for the Jib task
on whichever other tasks
you want to run it after.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What about
setting volume amounts
you need to import--
QINGYANG CHEN:
Yes, so currently,
we don't have a way to define
volume amounts that you set
that's burned into the
image, but if you're running
the image on, say,
Kubernetes, you
can define the volume
amounts for the container.
Yeah.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it
configurable if I do not
want to use distroless?
APPU GOUNDAN: Yeah, so he's
asking if it's configurable
if you don't want to use
the base image distroless.
Distroless is just
the default we use.
There's an option to
change where you're
pulling your base image from.
You can use Alpine
or whatever you want.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
APPU GOUNDAN: I'm sorry?
QINGYANG CHEN: JFrog.
Yeah.
You're talking
about the Java agent
that you want to add, right?
AUDIENCE: JFrog [INAUDIBLE].
QINGYANG CHEN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: JFrog registry.
APPU GOUNDAN: Oh, their
container registry.
QINGYANG CHEN: Oh,
So the container
registries-- it should
support most cloud providers
for container registries.
You can also even use
a private registry
that you set up
yourself, so you can--
for example, you can even
push it to a local registry
if you want.
So you can run a local registry.
You can just have it be
local host, whatever port,
slash whatever image.
So the first part of
that image reference
is going to be the registry
that you want to push it to.
So whichever other Container
Registry that you want to use--
it should be able to do it.
If it doesn't, let us know.
We'll try to fix it.
APPU GOUNDAN: It's
not built specifically
for Google Cloud Registries.
QINGYANG CHEN: Yeah.
APPU GOUNDAN: Or Google
Container Registry,
but you have to set
up auth on your own.
AUDIENCE: It GitHub,
it said [INAUDIBLE]
QINGYANG CHEN: Yeah,
there might be some--
AUDIENCE: So what's
the difference?
QINGYANG CHEN: There might
be some credential issues
with a [INAUDIBLE] registry
that we haven't figured out yet,
but we're still working on that.
All right.
APPU GOUNDAN: All right.
QINGYANG CHEN: Cool.
APPU GOUNDAN: Thanks for
listening, guys and girls.
[APPLAUSE]